hi I'm Charlie puth and I'm going to be
reacting to headlines about myself Shawn
Mendes insists Charlie puth is the only
one sending Jim selfies I mean I think
we took one picture of us working out
while we were on the Jingle Ball tour in
2015 somehow that ever vest into like
this mountain of Oh Charlie all Charlie
and Shawn do and beside them being
musicians they just did take Jim selfies
I think people just make mountains out
of molehills Noah Cyrus and little zan
have broken up over a fake Charlie puth
mood I was I'm still so confused over
that I were just remember seeing that
you know they have the little verified
section on Twitter you can see all the
verified accounts and I saw that picture
of me and I'm like that's definitely not
my body I'm not that ripped I saw the
little eggplant emoji
I was like okay it's a joke and I kind
of just paid it no mind woke up the next
day and it was very confused as to the
reason that was the reason why they have
chosen to break up I'll never understand
that but whatever no I don't even I
really don't believe any of them see now
this is very interesting when Charlie
puth wants the launch she tells his
driver I'm hungies I've never said that
and I've had multiple people come up to
me and be like Charlie I'm a huge fan
hungies I remember I was going to get
food and I said I was really hungry the
lady must have misheard me I don't know
why I don't even know if hungies is a
word why would I say that
now Charlie puth has candles what does
that even mean you know I like candles I
have candles Charlie puth explains his
questionable new hair color and tragic
fashion choices I've definitely made
some tragic fashion choices in the past
in fact I think I've been doing that
since like the third grade I remember
coming in
my hair would be blonde so apparently I
haven't really changed but you know I
think I said in the past that I you know
I have to do all this stuff or else I'm
not gonna be able to cringe with delight
so I wouldn't have it any other way
questionable hair color that's so [ __ ]
Charlie puth admits he likes older women
while totally hitting on these hosts
this is not accurate at all I was just
simply being a gentleman I was just what
he's supposed to be brewed to people who
interview you on a on a daytime
television show and that's and then Liam
Payne explains that he and Charlie puth
had a falsetto off when recording
bedroom floor partially true I wouldn't
call it a falsetto off it was more of me
just singing to him hey Liam sing this
arm this way and he sang it back to me I
guess he could consider that as a
falsetto off but mostly just producer
telling the artists how to sing which he
did very well inside Charlie puth scary
illness on tour I had to get shots in my
butt to get on stage yeah I remember
that like it was yesterday it was 2016
and I remember my tour manager talking
about let's go into Canada right out of
the show and I remember I just hadn't
slept in a week I remember I'm seeing my
parents in the audience and they could
just kind of tell that like I was just
like I had to stop I remember it was a
kind of a sad moment that I was in
somewhere in upstate New York and I was
like guys I'm sorry I can't do this
anymore but everyone in the audience was
like super nice everyone stood up and
all the mothers in the audience like
applauded me for making that decision
even though everybody was bummed out I
was
I just try and block this out of my
memory I don't remember what shots I was
taking but I remember I ended up in the
hospital I seriously think if I had gone
to Canada I would have been in way way
rougher shape because it's helped to sit
him to make at the time but a very good
decision fresh start
Charlie puth debuts shaved head after
deleting all of his Instagram photos
honestly there's not really much to this
it was summer and I woke up one day it
was really hot in the valley where I was
and like I'm just gonna shave my head
and I shaved my head and I announced to
myself that I wasn't hot anymore
that's it there's a little bit more
substance to that I think I just wanted
a fresh start because I have some
interesting fashion choices in the past
so I guess fresh start is correct what I
would like to say is that I don't Google
myself I don't read articles about
myself I did see the little Sam thing
because that thing is very funny but God
can hate the Internet
[Music]